copier Spike célèbre sa journée jusqu'à
dimanche prochain la première semaine
nationale du chien est organisée dans
l'Hexagone promenade en forêt
démonstrations d'attelage ou atelier
pédagogique diverses manifestations
visent à promouvoir le rôle bénéfique
des canidés et forment les futurs
adoptants au club d'éducation canine à
morpa des présentations été proposé au
public ce dimanche 1er octobre vous avez
également pu voir des démonstrations de
ring
qui est un programme
national de qui allie des exercices
d'obéissance des exercice de saut et un
programme de défense on travaille plus
dans le jeu que dans le que dans la
contrainte donc il faut capter son chien
et puis lui lui faire comprendre qu'on
veut jouer avec lui pour l'amener à
faire des exercices une occasion aussi
de mettre en avant l'activité du club
lors de ses portes ouvertes ici des
éducateurs diplômés et bénévoles
enseignent au propriétaires comment bien
éduquer leurs chiens une de mieux vivre
avec son animal il y en a pas mal des
gens qui ont des chiens comme compagnie
mais ils savent pas se comporter avec
des chiens et ils ne savent pas
comment s'exprime un chien sensibilisé
au langage canin dans ce club à morpa
l'accent était aussi mis sur la
prévention des risques de morsure durant
cette journée dans le département des
ibines d'autres manifestations seront
organisées jusqu'au 8 octobre pour
promouvoir l'animal préféré des
Français